hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to neverending
nightmares this may be the last episode
but then again I don't really know I
don't feel like I'm solving any
mysteries about why I'm here all I know
that I got more friendly friends over
there and I'm about to bleed aren't I no
no I'm gonna definitely avoid it because
I imagine that if I cut my feet they
would be able to smell the blood oozing
out from between my Tootsie's okay now
please please do not tell me that I
actually need to look in any of these
because I okay that was unimportant I'm
just gonna assume that there's nothing
important here and then I actually do
not need to look in them but I'm gonna
look anyway because there's a crops
grabbing flap open over there and I
really want to know who wants to grab my
crotch nobody oh okay fine then come on
come on come on come on they don't see
nothin I think it was up I think it was
down low oh he's moving oh he's a shifty
shifter oh he's a cross Walker oh I see
I see how he does he goes diagonally and
then he stays on the top and now it's
gonna probably go diagonally right into
me whoa that's weird you're weird
don't be weird don't be weird
don't be word you're not weird you're
not weird you're so normal
oh you're so normal oh I was so close
I was so close god dammit dammit dammit
dammit dammit with you damn this
whatever fine do this again cuz I'm not
an idiot
don't caught your tootsies on there
I don't need to look in every one of
those things because there's nothing
important
why can I even look at him if there's
nothing important in him it's a stupid
red herring I hate I still got the
volume like way cranked up loud no no
okay I thought he was gonna cross down
to me with your noise and your
creepiness I know her b'doop b'doop
okay I'm out of here go buy everybody an
old friend how are you doing you're not
gonna cross to be a douche are ya
no no no no you're gonna cross out of my
way so you're not a douche yeah yeah
yeah yeah just walk straight now yeah
that's it that's it that's it oh no no
no you don't see oh no no no no I hate I
hate you I hate you I hate you
completely I hate everything about you
you're literally the worst you're the
worst he's the worst he is literally the
worst hi no touching don't touch I ain't
touching you oh no no you and your cross
he's stupid it's so stupid
he's so stupid maybe would be easier to
cross from the top I don't know
oh I'm so bad at games in general I'm
just the worst no no I barely read I'm
the worst
I am literally the worst oh I can walk
right by you song as I don't touch you
I'm an idiot I thought I had to know I
thought I thought if I never mind I'm
dumb well I could have walked right by
them at any time as long as I wasn't
running I would have been fine I'm just
a goober no I was you just said I could
do you just said you just did that how
many times have I died how many I've
died more than any other person who
played this game I guarantee you I'm
going for the world record of most
useless deaths throughout all my games
everyone I played most useless deaths
King markiplier king of the losers best
loser ever that's now yeah I'm going I'm
going anyway your screw you screw screw
yo I'm out I'm Audi going into security
cuz alright there we go
done and done done and over with da
Neroni that's a lot of blood you guys
alright so I'm carrying on because I
have no idea what's waiting me in the
next area I really hope it's more Asylum
cuz this is not fast okay sorry I don't
mean to be bitter because I'm bad at
that I just did not know that I could
keep walking so long as I wasn't here I
thought if they were facing me if I
walked I would have been killed I don't
know why I thought that I'm just
thinking I'm too smart that's my problem
I'm just too smart about games or
something like that
well something exploded back there
that's good I like how all the cells are
progressively getting worse or better
depending on what kind of demonic entity
you actually are or I actually am I'm
talking about the character I don't wake
up
why don't what part of never ending
nightmare don't you understand wake up
means nothing to me I am asleep because
I'm in a coma or something like that
showers good need a cold shower to
forget about all the nightmare that's
going on in my face oh this is the blood
shower I'm sorry I went in the wrong one
so what could have come out of the
shower that could have possibly exploded
people in the bottom part whatever
that's a funtastic place let me never go
in there ever again oh god more oh
there's all the body parts I've been
wondering I've been really that is wait
oh that's all of my dead bodies no
that's not me I thought that would have
been me That's not me that's not me
where's the other one whoa
well someone escaped by turning into
blood and then slipping through the bars
he's a smart one that guy he's a genius
here's me barn me I have a great
thirsting need to go around you but you
seem to be blocking up the only path
wait a minute Oh is there a alcove in
here that I'm supposed to duck into it's
so true oh this is beautiful
thank you help me help hurtin oh yes
the go-fuck-yourself conference is over
to the left also my jokes suck so shut
up see what's in here some new na na
more the same weight that's l1 why did
we loop backwards to sell one also giant
pile of dead bodies anyone want to talk
about that one No Oh even bigger pile of
blood I love that my questions are
progressively getting more screwed over
got quieter in here I don't like it when
it gets quieter Oh
less blood are we going to the nicer
part please tell me we are I think all
the blood is actually moving out of the
asylum cells and into my brain well okay
goddamnit did I just loop over and over
again can I not do something right and I
have to be subjected to this over and
over again yes yes oh that is pristine
okay where am I now everything is uh hmm
everything is a white what could you
possibly mean hello friend
everything is a wide-open no no no no
them no yeah yeah you go you go no no no
Oh God broken glass oh what's going on
I've told you repeatedly to address me
as dr. Smith but you're my sister
I'm afraid you're mistaken you're in a
lunatic asylum for quite some time
why am I here why do you think you're
here
we've reached the end of our session
please see yourself out
okay bye Gaby hope you don't die
horribly and I hope I'm less insane
later hello all right you're my sister
maybe I'm just gonna come around your
side of the desk hug you tell you my
sister also wallpaper I want to say I'd
like it a lot definitely not just a
bunch of death okay bye
okay bye now take good bye good bye
oh god I'm still here I was hoping I
hadn't left yet
Oh gray Oh the pie why my god why have
you forsaken me everybody
it's the pile any bigger than it was
before I really hope it's improved my
cell - all blocked up by dead bodies and
once again are those my dead bodies they
don't have stripes on how am I supposed
to get around you no no no no don't make
no sense what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to die am I am I supposed to
die you're gonna make me die aren't you
pop here we go
Oh mommy
don't know what's that hello hello again
how are you doing
Gabi Gabi oh hello sir who the hell are
you I don't know looks like Tom Arnold
who's crying what is everything okay
alright well I'm going back screw you
screw you screw you screw I'm going in
whoa hey Gabi you got a thing outside
your door on your next appointments here
yeah Gabi Gabi gu gimme gimme gob ooh
hey Gabi party got me fine fine okay
I don't think Abby can hear me just
wondering if you're still out here are
you
no oh good oh I see
ow and my foot seas are all bloody must
be something to do with this
who maybe you would get you would think
that I'm smart I'm super smart I'm so
smart I'm not gonna make it
ah I get it I get it I get it I get it I
get it I get it I get it I get it I'm
smart I got it
okay I got it I got it I got it I got it
I got it you guys probably got a long
time ago but I got it now hey wow you're
you're on it you're on it man you're in
it to win it
good job man good job you almost got it
good sport
good job sport nice effort nice hustle
out there blood okay moving on moving on
to the nightmare that is my life
wake up I want to howl it really wrong I
would like to waking up is exactly the
best part of this day oh oh it's coming
out of the ceilings down I predicted
that I predicted that it was gonna come
out else shining style dreams are the
enemy of the guilty okay so I'm what am
i guilty of exactly is the mystery about
to be solved here because I really don't
know what's going on all my feetsies I
keep steppin on broken glass everything
is all a lie
oh okay although only the cake was a lie
hahahaha that joke is very old now now
the whole floor is coated with blood
I got a bad feeling something bout is
gonna happen now the exit I believe you
Oh Oh Daryl leaked their leaked asylum
it's like Zoolander I just step off into
infinity here goodbye no I'm humping the
darkness I didn't think I could walk a
white okay wait a minute here who eat a
minute here what else is happening
you don't run that by me again little
kid you don't run that by me again cuz I
don't know what's going on here anyway
I'm all out of time for this part I'm
thinking I'm very close to the end of
this heck I may be right at the end of
it and I don't know but either way I'm
gonna end this here if it's too short in
the next file just stitch it together so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Oh